(Applause)
(Music)
Angella Ahn: Thank you.
(Applause)
Thank you so much.
We are so honored to be here at TEDWomen,
sharing our music with you.
What an exciting and inspiring event.
What you just heard is "Skylife" by David Balakrishnan.
We want to play you one more selection.
It's by Astor Piazzolla, an Argentine composer.
And we talk about different ideas --
he had this idea
that he thought music should be from the heart.
This was in the middle of the 20th century
when music from the heart, beautiful music,
wasn't the most popular thing in the classical music world.
It was more atonal and twelve-tone.
And he insisted on beautiful music.
So this is "Oblivion" by Astor Piazzolla.
Thank you.
(Music)
(Applause)